hey welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for finiman finally finally
sorry celebrate New Year's Day yeah well
look if you haven't seen the show before
we're talking about the Australia for
venom and gonna get our thoughts or
feelings and some deleted scenes at the
end that said I was here the last day
before break and the thought was floated
that I would just do it as like venom
and like Brock versions of myself like
good and evil then we immediately
decided that was too much work and we
just shoot it when you guys are back
from vacation we're all here yeah so
we're here and we've all forgotten what
happened in bed yeah I don't remember
this movie now I remember the feelings
it gave me which were not unpleasant I
think that people expected us to hate
venom more than Dan and I did Joe I
think you hated venom no I didn't you
hated venom admit it I can see it in
your eyes it's not why heman venom hater
I just you know these sjw's and they're
they're aliens any time it did not do a
superhero movie thing I was super on
board and then any time it was like time
to do the superhero movie things i was
like no i liked dan i think i think it
was you it was one of you that was like
a certain things going to happen in the
movie and you're either on board or
you're not it was you it loves eating
lobster tank yeah
and so the lobster he sat in the lobster
tank and I was like Dan is that's the
thing cuz I'm on board that's the major
break version yeah sweaty perpetually
sweaty before it gets be a very swell
hearty fancy San Francisco restaurants
tank yeah super into that that was a
moment watching it in the theater at
which I myself consciously realized that
I was indeed on board yep this film but
that that would also be the point at
which some people be like what and would
immediately jump off board I this is
kind of amazed in my brain because I've
had venom being thrown at me for the
last three months
every time I like or don't like a movie
I get told that I either that you should
or should not count my opinion mainly
you should not count my opinion because
I did like about them so if I like them
you the movie it's like let's guy didn't
know what he's talking about he liked
venom and I don't like a movie it's well
this guy didn't know what he's talking
about he liked venom so that's the
challenge of a review yes I liked venom
I didn't like I am also not going to say
that venom was particularly a good movie
yeah well you can like something on its
own terms or for what it's set out to do
and I think it's said unto make a semi
ridiculous superhero movie and in that
it succeeded it's not like venom aroma
what do you get that one's gotta be
better than the other like duh but it's
not like scraping cars dropping bars I'm
a maid getting paid Roma I want to see
that movie now when she jumps into the
lobster tank to save the kids I want to
see sort of the ocean is there's lobster
tank the ocean is nature's lobster tank
that's true they really are more alike
than than you would think
yeah they're not so different but I do
think that this was all held together by
Tom Hardy's Manic Pixie dream boy I'm
already is the whole reason this works
if this had been I literally think of
this about anyone else but Tom Hardy
this movie would not have worked
which is weird cuz when they announced
him as Eddie Brock I said what yeah okay
yeah and yeah he's crazy
I thought venom looked cool the actual
venom yeah III think they obviously had
a I don't want to say limited budget but
less than some of these other tentpole
movies do and I thought that they pulled
everything off except for the action at
the end which I think we point out that
we also theater and I don't think anyone
else got that winamp joke but its venom
is a hard character to to bring to life
because the fighter man well no like
just visually yeah because if you don't
there's like if you do too much and like
over
design it then he looks like a Michael
Bay transformer where it's like oh we
added all sort or he looks like the bad
guy he looks like riot raisin been
immune yeah he looks like raisin venom
it's like a tough it's like the whole I
know like at what point this people is I
know the Hulk looks fake oh yeah at what
point does a 10-foot tall green
bodybuilder not look fake yeah if you go
photorealistic
yeah it's not really gonna work and I
don't know if that's achievable but it
looks like a cartoon like he's a 10-foot
tall green man anything above angly
level I'm gonna be okay well yeah so
many fangs like he can't physically
close his mouth without cutting his own
face give him a break we don't have like
a mental like equivalent for that to
make to be like okay that checks out
that looks real right you've never seen
the Hulk or venom in real life yeah so I
thought they did a good job with that
especially considering it didn't you
know have the the giant budget yeah all
right so let's take a look at what we
thought two weeks ago about venom then
what we saw for our remember how to do
this show
from the studio that Marvel let's play
with their toys comes the spider-man
fill and everyone wanted to see how
screen until they did hey Parker but
this time if they can't even afford to
put spider-man in it then of a rant
about thought Tobey Maguire but I
realized that rants really as the genre
runs out of Silver Age heroes to adapt
and enters the extreme 90s era of
leather jackets and attitude for
argument so much better they were rated
R Us there's a quote from Tom in front
about venom and like like it was when I
was in the context of like critics
versus fans remember and it was like
it's got everything it's got a big venom
in it to the effect of like it's got
lots of action and a big venom yeah for
three pairs of Jenko chief his mom lets
him wear it outside or not yeah I know
he's got hemlock ones on ya and I do
think that this would have been a really
fun um kind of like grindhouse movie if
it was rated R and you could see venom
just like you know deep blue sea style
of just like CGI sprays of blood sure me
much yeah you know yeah i that i was
reading todd Farlander this interview
about spawn mmm-hmm I'd like to
interview some is this not gonna be this
cutesy comic book thing people like what
spots not gonna be fun it's like who do
you think Todd McFarlane is layout this
is the guy who created spiky capes like
no this is no not gonna be [ __ ]
murders childhood and goes to hell I
think in other there's been like periods
of fun spawn but mostly it's like gritty
homeless alley yeah Eddie if he's not in
hell fighting a child molester he's in
he's in a hobo
in town and stitching up his face with a
shoelace fighting a child bless I'm
taking it dead serious yeah it's like
it's the no-win scenario with comic
books it's like they made a spawn movie
John Leguizamo and it was like he's -
she's just too silly it's too dumb for a
comic movie and then they make another
ones like this is gonna be harder
educate he's like I'm not interested
like then what do you do what do you
want him
what do you know what no one will ever
be happy with it right and I think venom
like they really toed the line with
pg-13 they did as much as they possibly
could yeah just almost distracting at
that point because like people are
reacting to such violence yeah there was
no blood spray when he been off that
head yeah yeah that off that off-camera
head bye and what so what's really
disappointing to me is that they had a
chance to do like this is the most
obvious
unrated director's cut move of all time
or at least all that footage that Tom
Hardy was talking about that they cut 40
minutes out I think there was any film
in the camera that was the 40 minutes of
pages he wrote yeah yeah we'll do those
Thursday Tommy Wow yeah I guess that's a
good point
probably just had him riff and they
stopped shooting a long time ago and
kind
everybody's at lunch yeah we wanted this
to be a closed set to really get a
strong performance today we value your
your work as an artist Tom yeah yeah
it's like just by seeing it the red
sauce so it's like Bobcat Goldthwait oh
wait it's San Francisco not New York but
he's like from Spitz basically space to
Brooklyn to San Francisco that's a FedEx
yeah yeah that's how that works
it's captivating keep going but it made
almost a billion dollars so what do we
know it's Venice Tom Hardy doing just
the most with a roll of Eddie Brock as
he plays the investigative reporter like
a crackhead squirrel Nicky
it'll just ya you'll be captivated by
his New York accent I have spent a
significant amount of time with one of
these creatures of changing man
bracelets yeah and so many weird little
noises you're wondering they've been
covering his mouth for a reason he acts
from the guns we haven't filled
I know CGI I notice a ding will get
called out on often for honest trailers
it's just like oh they just put together
a run of things to make it look crazier
than it really is but you know what's
funny
hmm and edited together list of things
to make we're not taking them from other
movies like that's in venom we may have
stretched a little bit on the science
talk perhaps we did overlay I think we
may have done a little too much of the
science talk we're also wanting to go
home that's true I'm full full
disclosure I left a couple days early
the first time I saw this trailer was
uploaded to YouTube because I was like
oh well they're do I know that there's
even less effort not effort lots of
effort to get it done in time vacation
for next we're gonna do my final notes
on this one from the sky I saw the email
then I had to go back to airplane mode
and I was like Spencer's done a lot of
these this is fine I think it turned out
great
it did it's abuse yeah really wish I put
a little more focus on this one and so
how deep can you get it I wish we had
done a song that's all I we should have
done we should have done a song but we
just didn't have done them we are
associative I forgot we didn't make a
upgrade joke oh yeah just Kinnaird yeah
upgrade being you know
the venom that came out first the yeah
yeah guys it looks almost exactly like
tomar yeah yeah thanks so insert your
own upgrade joke yeah one of it right
here yeah right here is where your
upgrade oh man keep going by an evil
splooge from outer space who goes by
venom a member of a parasitic race it's
gonna conquer earth unless humanity can
somehow get its hands on a halfway
decent sound system they there's a venom
logic thing that they set up and then
completely abandoned that I remember of
like you gotta find like a very
particular host for venom like venom can
only venom eyes with you know a few
people long term or and venom is like
the village bicycle man everyone gets a
ride on venom
well I will fight back which is that
anyone can host venom for a short period
of time
however there were very many people that
could actually bond with him and a
person what was wrong with that lady
took six months to get to the airport
that's a good question and that's a huge
oversight on the case of the movie which
is I think that's part of why they
should have just leaned hardcore into
the relationship angle because that's
what venom like he can he can date for
for a short cameraman it's like there's
only a special someone yeah it takes a
really special what you didn't know is
that she was very ill the whole time
yeah sweaty clam very ill and I'm um
Radian just exploded yeah exactly that
was one of Tom Hardy's favorite parts
that got cut yeah venom has that same
transformers logic problem where it's
like were you named jazz before you came
comes from a planet that's just all like
two thousand represents Brian
toxin venom what a sick ass planet I
think it's like a Man of Steel thing you
like on my planet this means hope
different alien is just on this planet
in me yes I don't know pretty upfront
about it but yeah you're right it could
be a translation yeah yeah I wonder if
it's a common name like his venom like
Dandridge
the venom with venom Zeenat maravattai
right um you're tall venom yeah yeah
well we'll visit there and venom too
like how Luke I'm Krypton like L was
like Smith yeah kal-el was like John on
my yeah let's keep watching venom any
day they'll chomp their way bad guys
alike prompting audiences everywhere to
wonder Mortal Kombat is he technically a
cannibal
when venom bites off a head does Eddie
have to crap out the skull later I guess
somebody Chris got out of containment
gods and voids of science talk you
discovered a gene this is just basically
we didn't like any part of the movie
that Tom Hardy wasn't it right
we can pause to talk about the abilities
that are briefly yeah not good not
suited not suited for and Jenny slate
odd choice choices yeah I don't think is
that I think people thought we saying
the science talk was complicated ya know
there was just a great volume of it and
I skipped the step from like is this CEO
like an evil maniacal killer to just
like he's an evil man
he's an evil maniacal killer and nobody
would hold that secret for very long he
is very quick to murder they did give
him one there's one great scene which I
will give the movie like tons of props
because we always yell about show don't
tell hmm and the scene where he's doing
the Q&A with the kids and a kid asked
him a question and he's just like and
I'm leaving and she's gonna answer your
question rightly but he still gets the
applause for a great like this is
everything you need to know about like
this guy scene which which I dug and
then yeah and then he went full stuff
yeah he was just really like he really
dug into giving the speech to certain
Drifters but not others like does he do
that every time that they venom eyes
somebody securities like oh here we go
again
oh boy he's going up to the glass okay
that's lunch your name is Michael your
name is Casey like the man who supported
the Ninja Turtles through the time
indeed yeah yeah once upon a time he was
that bad but this swing you will strike
I'm going to bat for the human race and
you're not just saving New York you're
going to save the planet yeah
which we'll get to in a minute yeah
you're hard for your body to maintain
homeostasis is arenal endocrine their
protein running Diagnostics even fully
automated you can't pilot that craft all
alone directing the boredom is the not
so secretly evil Carlton Drake a man who
wants to destroy humanity in order to
save it we brought the planet to the
brink of extinction a plan shared by
this film's villain infinity Wars
Mission Impossible fallouts and the
Predators and that's just in 2018 real
no more this you know moratorium we're
done no more I'm saving humanity by
killing humanity that even the
environmentalists gone too far
yeah the humanity is the real enemy I
get it we live in a cold climate channel
no more yeah done no more right now
Airport Books played it out in like the
late 90s yes oh yeah movies have finally
yeah I think it's like the Tom Clancy
has done this there's the studio note or
like the the like basic screenwriting
advice of like make the hero or make the
villain think he's the hero of the story
it was like okay well he has to want to
destroy the whole world so what good
reason is there for that he thinks it's
for good yeah okay again that's lunch
it's a Poochie it's a Poochie motivation
so motivation be kill humanity save it
yep
kind of a weekly week motivation where
we're over it or you're done come on
yeah form raison venom then try to cheer
on the hero as the action concludes with
two syrupy blotches wrestling each other
like a Winamp visualizer with T it
really rips the long as that's a one
percenter yeah yeah maybe a point five
maybe a point this happens when you guys
go to vacation a day early you can't say
no you're on an airplane I thought it
was weird that you wrote a winamp joke
every trailer this year yeah that's the
thing that when you launch win app and
press play that's the little test sound
yeah if you guys recall I dad that's the
kind of joke that like not everyone's
gonna get with the people that get in a
row I hope they do yeah even if it's
just me I appreciate I got it every
Christmas I like this that and this
great double konista shirt polka visa
all right keep going
it's not just an action movie it's also
a love story as Eddie is torn between
his love of Michelle Williams terrible
wig I'm sorry about that and the special
- we know it's not weird that I ships in
Brock the movie made a quarter billion
in China and this is how they advertised
it ever since tumblr changed this is all
I got left we have this wood
[Music]
EPIK Boise likee
Oh another chapter an epic voice guys
let him have it yeah ever since they
took pornographic images off tumblr all
he's got is venom yeah I guess he's
moved on from the Fifty Shades trilogy
you got to at some point you got to keep
things spicy yeah there are a few things
honest trailers has introduced me to
Sonic fan art yep and SCIM Brock yeah
which I did not realize was such a thing
but it's very much a thing yep
I believe the the current writer of
venom is currently being shouted out a
lot online because that is not this
focus of his venom comic Oh No yeah
there's still time to pivot yeah yeah
that's all that's all people just want
their goop horn yeah they want venom
inside them yeah yeah it really was set
up like a kind of like a love triangle
because he was like there's this new
exciting thing in his life and and then
volition with Michelle Williams I don't
know I don't think that's got a future I
think that's going anywhere it was
already hacking her computer and stuff
like that and she was already like
helping hide you know disappeared
drifters on her computer that's right it
should have been formatted as like venom
is the like Tom Hanks Tom Hardy is the
meg Ryan hmm Michelle Williams is Meg
Ryan's like crappy husband that the
audience is like we don't like you yeah
that that should have been the the folks
that I instead it was venom constantly
being like we're gonna get you back
together with Michelle we yeah but it's
like now but I guess at the end they're
just like some sort of like poly
throuple listen I think they know which
way to go now yeah that's how they
marketed the blu-ray was as a romantic
comedy yeah I'm actually glad that they
barely somehow managed to pull this off
at least box-office wise cuz I think at
least they now have a wind vane of which
way to go and it's pointing right at sym
Brock I don't think they had enough
development of that relationship it was
kind of jarring but like okay whatever
when the movie was like wouldn't venom
just stops him he's like I had a change
of heart I was a loser too that's a bad
time and you kind of remind me of me
let's go
I like third act that part of the movie
I can't explain it okay I'm weird no
it's fine it's just like you know I
would have liked to see more time spent
on their relationship I think what it is
is I
I've tried Remember Who Oh mark barnard
and tweeted this he was talking about
Aquaman where he was like he was just
talking about he didn't emotionally
connect to anyone and he was like CG is
CG now and I've seen really great epic
CG stuff and it's gonna take more to
impress me at this point I need
something to like latch on to and I
think that's where like more time on
weird stuff with venom because we get it
we know like everyone can recite to you
the superhero three-act structure now
everybody gets it everybody so yeah any
time they went paint-by-numbers
including the post-credits ting mmm
words like it's gonna be character name
I fell off and then anytime they were
like let's do something weird I was like
I was right back in yeah okay well we
know where to go for venom to going so
enjoy a comic book film that is involved
down by 20 other episodes like the MCU
or the grandiose pretensions of the DC
Universe is amazing but sometimes it's
fun to watch a movie that's just a movie
I like I do to kick start an entire
cinematic universe porn past Sony
hardpack made a lot of Legends lubber
story sad max inky and the vein from
beep and and from Dennis complete Sam
taster by the siege Elon Musk everyone
oops hit the Rialto Theatre as an as my
editing regrets came about here is like
okay Close Encounters of the Third Kind
going down the street please call your
gastroenterologist so that was a bad and
goo other than hating the fact that the
Sony once again put the last the scene
of a movie in a trailer criminal repeat
offenders yeah that was such a dumb line
to put in the last like as like the
marketing cuz I was i I was at comic-con
when they were in this trailer and when
that like whoever was like what yeah
okay it's from a book things are from
yeah you can choose out of context it's
just like what like what kind of movie
is this but then at the end of it when
it's like you see what the the dynamic
is it makes a lot more sense enemas yeah
yeah but like seeing that like to use
that as like the the last scene in the
trailer it's just like what are you
doing and then and then using the we are
venom literally the last line of the
movie one of them in the trailer it's
like wait why yes only put other moments
that would like make it make that make
sense more of like you know I'm hungry
feed me a dog okay chocolate like okay
that's the movie yeah yeah you know well
the clearer the marketing worked yeah
one way or another sometimes everyone is
so we know yeah did we finish yeah we
get extra stuff story Clark spent sweaty
broad emotional support cannibal
a boy and his blob monster energy bill
again whiter or heroin but that Gator is
a mad carnage table and corn seriously
answer they're going with for garnish
okay everyone goop's used the worst part
of Michelle Williams wig she already
looked like the character yeah is the
six-week pious so six months to get the
airport
she looks very unwell that's what I'm
saying sure but at the same time like
but why did it take her six months to
get to six months you could cover a lot
of ground in there I agree she's walking
very slowly yeah
impaired or not okay yeah I think we we
expelled all the venom inside yeah we
learned a lot we we made a song sort of
yeah yeah for aroma at least yeah you're
welcome you're welcome well we've
covered a lot of ground yeah we covered
everything if you have more venom
questions hit us up on Twitter well
they'll be promptly ignored but do come
back next week for another honest
trailer commentary for something that's
going to be hmm I don't know it might
end differently than you think
yeah yeah yeah so we'll leave it with
that yeah
and it's good to be back guys 20:19 nice
trail commentaries boom
[Music]
you